[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien schönen guten Abend ihnen
allen Katja Stresow hat heute Fußball
und tolles Tennis im Angebot eine schöne
Mischung ja schönen guten Abend wir
schauen gemeinsam auf den Überblick
[Musik]
Vorstoß im Osten damit er
Überraschungserfolg der Ukraine nicht
umsonst war muss Deutschland jetzt mehr
schwere Waffen liefern fordern Grüne und
FDP
Schweizer Atommüll direkt an der Grenze
unsere Nachbarn planen für ihre
Brennstäbe ein Endlager nahe
Baden-Württemberg dort ist man skeptisch
vom Wunderkind zum Champion mit gerade
mal 19 gewinnt Carlos alcaras die US
Open wird zur Nummer 1 im Tennis und hat
noch viel vor
[Musik]
die Ukraine erobert immer mehr Gebiete
in der Region rakif zurück und das
innerhalb weniger Tage in Kiew spricht
der Präsident von einem Durchbruch und
auch Militärexperten sehen beachtliche
Erfolge aber noch keinen Wendepunkt
schließlich bleiben noch immer 20% der
Ukraine besetzt trotzdem die
Gebietsverluste werden in Russland
diskutiert dazu gleich mehr zunächst zur
Lage in der Ukraine Kathrin Eigendorf
und Kristina Kaiser
ukrainische Soldaten feiern ihren Sieg
und zerstören die russische Flagge ein
Symbol für den überraschenden Erfolg
dutzende Panzer wurden stehen gelassen
fluchtartig haben sich die Russen
zurückgezogen aufatmen bei den Menschen
in den nun befreiten Gebieten
es reicht nicht zu sagen dass ich
glücklich bin mir fehlen einfach die
Worte
wir hatten Tränen in den Augen wir haben
uns so gefreut dass unsere Jungs
gekommen sind sie haben so tolle Arbeit
geleistet
große Gebietsgewinne seit Tagen 20
Ortschaften sollen allein in den letzten
24 Stunden befreit worden sein auch die
russische Militärverwaltung der Region
rakif bestätigt im russischen Fernsehen
die Übermacht der ukrainischen Truppen
die Gegenoffensive übertraf unsere
Streitkräfte ungefähr um das Achtfache
ich denke daher hat das Kommando wohl
beschlossen sich zurückzuziehen sich neu
zu formieren um unser Personal zu
schonen
gleichzeitig bleibt die Stadt Traggriff
im Visier es gibt weiter Luftangriffe
vor allem auf die kritische
Infrastruktur ein Kraftwerk steht in der
Nacht in Flammen die Folge großflächige
Stromausfälle die Gebietsverluste
erklärt Russland heute mit einer
strategischen Umgruppierung der
Einheiten der Krieg soll weitergehen
die Operation wird fortgesetzt bis sie
anfangsgesetzten Ziele erreicht sind so
der kremlsprecher vor Journalisten auch
vor der Zivilbevölkerung in rakev machen
die Russen weiter keinen Halt pavel hat
die letzte Nacht in seinem Haus wie
durch ein Wunder überlebt
ich schlief in der zweiten Etage es gab
zwei Einschläge sie wollten
wahrscheinlich das Haus treffen das ist
das Ergebnis das ist ziemlich traurig
Resultat
fassungslos blickt er wie viele der
Einwohner auf die Trümmer draußen sind
bereits die Polizei und ein
Ermittlungsteam unterwegs alles wird
genau dokumentiert denn die Ukraine will
jeden russischen Anschlag als
Kriegsverbrechen zur Anklage bringen
wieder schwere Angriffe also in
haarkäfer und gleichzeitig russischer
Teil Rückzug für Bagger in Moskau also
wie werden die Gebietsverluste in
Russland gesehen wie werden sie
diskutiert
also in den russischen Staatsmedien der
wird schon auch über die sogenannte
Umgruppierung berichtet mit Fokus eben
auf den ukrainischen Verlusten aber
abseits davon da findet durchaus ein
bemerkenswerter ein interessanter
Tonwechsel statt zum Beispiel gibt es da
die 18 stadtabgeordneten aus Moskau und
aus St Petersburg Mitglieder der
Kommunistischen Partei und der Liberalen
parteiabloco die ganz offen Putins
Rücktritt gefordert haben sie
argumentieren das dessen aggressive
Rhetorik dazu geführt habe dass das Land
zurück in die Zeiten des Kalten Krieges
gerutscht sei und auch am anderen Ende
des politischen Spektrums unter den
ultra-nationalistischen Kommentatoren
Bloggern und Journalisten da wird
kritisiert zum Beispiel dass es bisher
noch keine general Mobilmachung gegeben
hat und dass der Präsident am Wochenende
lieber ein Riesenrad eingeweiht hat als
sich um die Ukraine zu kümmern all das
sind jetzt noch keine Sachen die die
Macht von Wladimir Putin gefährden aber
nach den letzten Monaten des Schweigens
als es hier eigentlich in Russland fast
gar keine kritischen Stimmen gab da sind
das eben doch ganz bemerkenswerte
Entwicklungen für bedanke für die
Einschätzung nach Moskau
die ukrainischen militärerfolge die
lösen in der Berliner Ampelkoalition
erneut Kontroversen aus man müsse Kiew
jetzt weiter unterstützen nun auch mit
Leopard 2 Kampfpanzern heißt es laut
heißt es fordernd aus der FDP auch die
Grünen können sich das vorstellen die
Kanzlerpartei die SPD bleibt bei ihrer
Linie und ist dagegen Andreas Huppert
berichtet
sie sind das Objekt der Begierde der
ukrainischen Militärs der deutsche
Kampfpanzer Leopard und der
Schützenpanzer Marder kommt ein Tag
vergeht an dem Kiew nicht fordert
liefert uns diese Waffensysteme eine
Bitte die bei der
Verteidigungsministerin bislang auf
taube Ohren stößt noch kein Land hat
schützen oder Kampfpanzer westlicher
Bauart geliefert und wir haben uns
darauf verständigt auch mit unseren
Partnern dass wir da keine deutschen
Alleingänge machen apropos Alleingänge
in der Ampelkoalition ist die SPD mit
dieser Haltung isoliert denn Grüne und
FDP wollen schnellstmöglich auch
Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine liefern
ich wünschte mir dass die
Verteidigungsministerin ihre Linie
ändert es geht jetzt darum dass wir an
der Seite der Ukraine stehen jetzt ist
das Momentum entsprechende Waffen zu
Unterstützung zu liefern es ist klar
dass wir mehr liefern müssen auch
schweres Gerät und dass wir uns dabei
alles anschauen müssen auch die Bestände
der Bundeswehr die Bestände der
Industrie Forderungen die der
Bundeskanzler ablehnt beim Besuch des
israelischen Ministerpräsidenten behaart
Olaf Scholz darauf keine Angriffswaffen
keine Kampfpanzer
wir werden diesen Weg weitergehen und
die Ukraine so lange unterstützen wie
das notwendig ist und wir haben auch bei
verschiedenen Gelegenheiten sehr
angeboten dass wir bereit sind wenn es
um die langfristige Sicherheit der
Ukraine gibt gerade im Bereich
Artillerie und Luftverteidigung unseren
Beitrag zu leisten
Kampfpanzer für die Ukraine ja oder nein
diese Frage im zweiten momentan die
Ampelkoalition
russische Bürger kommen seit heute
schwerer an Visa für Deutschland und
weitere EU-Staaten unter anderem müssen
sie mit längeren Bearbeitungszeiten und
Einschränkungen rechnen Grund dafür die
EU-Staaten haben ein visaabkommen mit
Russland komplett ausgesetzt als
Reaktion auf den russischen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
Wendepunkt im Ukraine Krieg diese Frage
greift ein zdf-spezial direkt nach
unserer Sendung auf und die Kollegen bei
ZDF heute live thematisieren ab 19:45
Uhr die wachsende Kritik an putinskrieg
in Russland in der ZDF heute App und auf
unseren Social Media Kanälen
Israels Regierungschef Lapid ist zu
Besuch in Berlin gemeinsam mit
Bundeskanzler Scholz traf er am
Nachmittag Holocaust Überlebende im Haus
der Wannseekonferenz dort hatten die
Nationalsozialisten vor 80 Jahren die
systematische Ermordung der Juden
beschlossen Jahr für Jahr gibt es
weniger Zeitzeugen die vom Holocaust
berichten können
das Menschheitsverbrechen der Shore
werden wir nie vergessen das Gedenken an
den millionenfachen Mord an den Jüdinnen
und Juden Europas ist eine immerwährende
Verpflichtung für uns es ist unsere
Verantwortung Lehren aus der
Vergangenheit zu ziehen und uns jeder
Form von Antisemitismus
entgegenzustellen
das Münchner ifo Institut prognostiziert
für den kommenden Winter eine Rezession
in Deutschland voraussichtlich werde die
Wirtschaft schrumpfen so die
Konjunkturforscher außerdem sei damit zu
rechnen dass die Inflationsrate steigt
in diesem Jahr auf 8,1 Prozent und im
kommenden auf 9,3 die hohe Inflation und
schlechte Aussichten für die Konjunktur
das sind schwierige Voraussetzungen für
die Tarifgespräche der IG Metall heute
gab es in Niedersachsen die erste
Verhandlungsrunde in der Branche sind
bundesweit 3,8 Millionen Menschen
beschäftigt die Gewerkschaft fordert 8%
mehr Lohn die Arbeitgeber halten das für
realitätsfremd und wollen eine Nullrunde
an seinem Stern berichtet
hier kommt der Antrieb her für viele
Schiffe auf der ganzen Welt die Firma
Reintjes in Niedersachsen die Getriebe
sind gefragt die Auftragsbücher voll die
Sorgen trotzdem enorm Zulieferungen
kommen viel zu spät und ist drohen wie
überall massive Mehrkosten bei Material
und Energie wir verbrauchen etwa 8
Millionen Kilowattstunden Strom pro Jahr
und jeder kann sich ausmalen was das
bedeutet wenn das um einige zehn Cent
steigt das sind immense Kosten für uns
mehr kosten mehr Unsicherheit für
Unternehmen und Angestellte die
Mitarbeiter brauchen jetzt dringend und
deutlich mehr Geld sagt die Gewerkschaft
jetzt geht es darum dass wir die
Probleme der Beschäftigten lösen in
dieser schwierigen Situation und eins
will ich da noch mal deutlich machen
gesamtgesellschaftlich ist das auch
unbedingt notwendig weil sonst haben wir
noch ein größeres zusätzliches Problem
das ist nämlich dass uns die
konjunkturzusammenbricht der private
Konsum ist im Moment die einzige Stütze
der konjunkturellen Entwicklung
reine Einmalzahlungen würden da eher
wenig helfen meint die IG Metall ihre
Position zum verhandlungsstart in
Hannover ist sehr klar die Antwort der
Arbeitgeber ist es auch 8 Prozent zu
fordern das ist aus der Zeit gefallen
und das passt nicht die IG Metall hat
ihre Forderung im Juni Juli entwickelt
da haben wir noch nicht von einer großen
insolvenzelle gesprochen da haben wir
noch nicht von diesen von dieser
wirklich schwierigen Lage unserer
Industrie gesprochen wir wussten aber
dass was auf uns zukommt und schon
damals war diese Forderung zu hoch
Verhandlungen die schwierig werden weil
die Folgen von Krieg und Krisen alle
treffen Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer im
ganzen Land
eine Million Jahre so lange soll der
Atommüll der Schweiz ab etwa 2050
dauerhaft in tongestein eingelagert
werden die jetzt beendete Endlagersuche
sorgt vor allem in Baden-Württemberg für
Aufregung der Grund das Endlager soll
direkt an der deutschen Grenze entstehen
der geplante Eingang der unterirdischen
Anlage liegt von der Gemeinde
Hohentengen am Rhein nur etwa zwei
Kilometer entfernt Sandra Susanka
berichtet über die Sorgen der Anwohner
überrascht uns skeptisch reagieren die
Bewohner von Hohentengen auf die
Schweizer Entscheidung denn vor sieben
Jahren wurde der Standort als ungeeignet
bewertet das luft- und
wasserundurchlässige tongestein würde zu
tief liegen die Schweizer packen es
einfach irgendwo ans Ende ihres Landes
hin
ja ich kenne niemanden der wirklich das
befürwortete von Anfang an das Gefühl
dass wir nichts daran ändern können dass
wenn die Entscheidung so getroffen wird
dass uns das dann einfach nur mitgeteilt
wird in der Region nördlich legern
unweit der deutschen Gemeinde
Hohentengen plant die Schweiz ein
Atommüll Endlager dort sollen die
radioaktiven Abfälle aus den vier
Atomkraftwerken der Schweiz in hunderten
Metern Tiefe eingebettet werden weitere
Prüfungen der nationalen Genossenschaft
für die Lagerung radioaktiver Abfälle
konnten nun die Unsicherheitsfaktoren
ausschließen heißt es bautechnische
Schwierigkeiten sind nicht so
standortkritisch wie wir gedacht haben
wir sind heute überzeugt wir können ein
Tiefenlager an jedem sofort sicher bauen
und betreiben frühestens in neun Jahren
könnten die Baumaßnahmen beginnen ab
2050 der Atome eingelagert werden doch
auf beiden Seiten der Grenze gibt es
noch Fragen gibt es tatsächlich ein
Sicherheitsrisiko was bedeutet das zum
Beispiel für die Konzepte der Transporte
das muss Punkt für Punkt überprüft
werden weder die Schweizer Regierung
noch das Parlament haben dem Vorhaben
bisher zugestimmt auch eine
Volksabstimmung könnte das Atommüll
Endlager noch verhindern
jetzt nach Schottland in die Hauptstadt
Edinburgh dort sind heute Tausende
unterwegs um ihrer Königin Farrell zu
sagen durch die Royal Mile in der
Altstadt führte die Prozession der Sarg
von Elisabeth der zweiten wird in der
Kathedrale aufgebaut bis morgen haben
die Schotten Gelegenheit Abschied zu
nehmen Andreas Stamm fast den Tag
zusammen
die Königin ist tot lang lebe der König
Charles hinter dem Sarg seiner Mutter
zum ersten Mal auf ihrer langen Reise
zur letzten Ruhe vom Palast in Edin
Brother zum offiziellen goodbye
Gedenkgottesdienst in Schottland in
seiner Liebe zum nördlichsten Landesteil
steht Charles seiner Mutter in nichts
nach doch seit Jahren verstärkt durch
den brexit steht die schottische
Unabhängigkeit im Raum die Queen war ein
Garant der Einheit Charles wird darum
kämpfen müssen
was seine Beliebtheit hier angeht steht
es 50 zu 50 aber wenn er erst mal besser
bekannt ist wird das schon gut gehen
manche wollen jetzt die Unabhängigkeit
noch mehr andere halten davon gar nicht
es wird auf jeden Fall noch mehr
debattiert werden
was bei der Entscheidung helfen könnte
wie seine Mutter will er sein selbstlos
pflichtbewusst so Charles am Morgen in
London als er die Beileidsbekundungen
bei der Parlamentskammern entgegen
ich bin zutiefst dankbar für ihre
Anteilnahme in der bewegen
zusammengefasst wird was für eine
Bedeutung die Verstorbene Herrscherin
meine geliebte Mutter die Königin für
uns alle hatte sie war ein Vorbild für
Monarchen durch alle Zeiten
gott schütze den König in London geht
das den Parlamentariern leicht von den
Lippen
in edinbrand soll Charles zum Schutzwall
gegen Unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen werden
der würdevolle Abschied von der Queen
ein Anfang bevor ihr sagt morgen nach
London geflogen wird
in New York befindet sich das Museum of
Modern Art das MoMA es zeigt ja wirklich
die größten der großen Werke von Picasso
von Chagall van Gogh und von Wolfgang
Tillmanns rund 350 Fotografien und
andere Arbeiten sind dort seit heute zu
sehen einer der bedeutendsten deutschen
Künstler in einem der bedeutendsten
Museen der Welt mit einer eigenen
Ausstellung Johannes Hano war dort für
uns vor 38 Jahren kam Wolfgang Tillmanns
zum ersten Mal ins MoMA als Besucher
jetzt wird er geehrt mit einer eigenen
Werkschau eine Ausstellung die ganz in
unsere Zeit passt zu Look without 4 ist
keine Angst zu haben die Wirklichkeit zu
akzeptieren zu analysieren was wir sehen
es ist die Ermutigung und die Hoffnung
und die Forderung ist in einer Welt zu
leben zu können in der ich ohne Angst
schauen darf
küssen schwitzen tanzen Abtauchen in die
Clubszene wie Lust am Körper ein
verspielter Umgang mit Sexualität
Tillmanns Fotos der 90er Jahre sind
Ausdruck des Lebensgefühls derzeit das
Werk fielseitig abstrakte Bilder in der
Dunkelkammer entstanden prägen für seine
Arbeit aber die Faszination für die
Unendlichkeit des Kosmos und das ist
glaube ich eine Basis für eine für eine
gewisse Demut und Bescheidenheit eben zu
akzeptieren nicht alles zu wissen und
gleichzeitig sich aber auch daran zu
erfreuen das zu akzeptieren und nicht
ersetzt werden muss durch Aberglaube
oder andere Ideologien
in der Morgenröte nach der Nacht im Club
Science Fiction hier und jetzt zufrieden
sein der Titel das Schlussbild einer
grandiosen Show des Berliner Künstlers
Wolfgang Tillmanns im New York am Museum
of Modern Art
wir sind jetzt beim Sport und da
verneigt sich die Tenniswelt vor einem
19-Jährigen hatte vor Carlos er hat die
US Open New York gewonnen und nicht nur
das durch den viersatzige Norweger
Kasper Rüth ist der Spanier nun auch
Weltranglisten erster
da lag er und konz nicht fassen der
erste Teenager als Tennis Nummer eins
[Applaus]
anfing war das mein Traum den Pokal
heute zu haben kaum zu glauben
gegen den Norweger Kasper rütt hier
unten im Bild schon bei den French Open
im Finale und jetzt Weltranglisten
zweiter kommt alkaraß nach einer
Schwächephase im zweiten Satz zu seinem
ersten Grand Slam Sieg mit sechs zu vier
zwei zu sechs sieben zu sechs und sechs
zu drei der Traum wird wahr im Heimatort
El Palmar im Südosten Spaniens feiern
sie den Wunderknaben alkaras löst den
Russen Daniel medve an der
Weltranglisten Spitze ab die Konkurrenz
findet ihren Meister fürs Erste in einem
19-Jährigen
ja und im Tennis Davis Cup wollte
Alexander Zverev ab kommenden Mittwoch
in Hamburg eigentlich sein Comeback
geben nach seinem mehrfachen Bänderriss
im rechten Fuß doch das deutsche Team
muss gegen Frankreich ohne Zverev
auskommen nach einem intensiven
Aufbautraining hat er nun ein
knochenödem im Fuß und fällt noch Wochen
vielleicht sogar Monate aus
gestern habe ich mit dem Oskar trainiert
und habe angefangen extrem Schmerzen in
meinem Fuß wieder zu haben konnte dann
irgendwann wirklich nicht mehr laufen
nicht mehr gehen
zur Fußball-Bundesliga Schlusslicht VfL
Bochum hat sich nach sechs Spieltagen
und null Punkten von Chefcoach Thomas
Reis getrennt U19 Trainer Heiko Butscher
übernimmt interimsweise und in der
Champions League empfängt Bayern München
morgen Abend in der Gruppenphase den FC
Barcelona dabei bereiten sich die Bayern
ganz besonders auf einen alten Bekannten
vor der heute mit Barca seinem neuen
Verein angekommen ist Robert Levi
Lewandowski will morgen für Verwirrung
sorgen der Radio der hat mir die letzten
zehn Tage schon immer sehr scherzhaft
gesagt ich soll auf keinen Fall dann aus
Versehen mal den Ball zu Levi spielen
wer keine gute Idee im ersten Spiel hat
er dreimal getroffen vielen Dank Katja
wenn sie außergewöhnliche Bauwerke oder
genauer gesagt Türme mögen dann haben
wir jetzt noch ein Reisetipp für Sie
gau-weinheim in Rheinland-Pfalz denn der
örtliche mittelalterturm ist jetzt
offiziell der schiefste der Welt das
Dorf hat Geld gesammelt um genau
nachmessen anderen Rekord registrieren
zu lassen
5,43 Grad Neigung da kann dann selbst
der berühmte Publikumsmagnet in Pisa
einpacken er ist zwar deutlich höher hat
aber gerade mal vier Grad Neigung
beim Wetter ist kräftiger Regen ein
Thema Details gleich von ostentally
meine einschalt Empfehlung für 21 Uhr
das heute journal mit Arne Gellinek ja
das war es von uns am Montag schönen
Abend für Sie und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der ehemalige
Hurrican Daniel liegt nun vor der
iberischen Halbinsel ist zu einem
normalen tief geworden und pumpt uns
feuchte und warme Luftmassen nach
Deutschland hier bildet sich eine
Luftmassengrenze aus denn aus dem Norden
strömt kühle Luft dagegen genau über der
Mitte wird es also kräftigen Regen geben
in den nächsten Tagen in der Nacht erst
einmal im Norden Regen der schwenkt
allmählich nach Osten ja im Süden ist es
trocken bei Temperaturen bis 8 Grad im
Südosten Deutschlands und an der Nordsee
um 16 Grad das ist die Temperaturspanne
und morgen regnet es noch etwas im Osten
Deutschlands es wird weniger aber dafür
bildet sich die Luftmassengrenze quer
über Deutschland aus und in der darauf
folgenden acht gibt es kräftigen Regen
ja und die Temperaturen dazu 29 Grad im
Südwesten Deutschlands deutlich wärmer
als im Vergleich Richtung
Schleswig-Holstein mit 18 Grad am
Mittwoch schüttet es kräftig bereits in
der Nacht auf Mittwoch 30 bis 50 Liter
bei Gewittern sogar mehr und die können
im Süden vor allem unwetterartig sein 16
bis 27 Grad und danach bleibt es
teilweise schauerartig nass ein schöner
Abend